[Music]
I don't even like naked like this you
can see this I'm like ABC well night
there's something so nostalgic about
this I'm trying really hard to be
offensive it I like this one cuz it's
like what a woman body actually looks
like I mean like eight to be over like a
teammate holy [ __ ] look at that sixties
was kind of like just like oh boy and a
girl I fail Bush was in big boy ways you
made no boy clear lack of diversity with
men they have the young men who are
really swollen of the pictures and
they're so like I'm a little bit more
sophisticated man I'm gonna read the
articles now this is too dirty and
there's I'm old I have to read the
articles so that I don't come off as a
pervert
she's so oh wait like figure out your
image what are you a few or no mag are
you like Vanity Fair if you're gonna
have the bra on why even have that yes
please thank you this is where it gets
dicey see this is more like wine I'm
expecting but they do have a redhead
really this is the centerfold this is
not a real person
one busty is not much hype I like more
traditional like kind of kind of hipster
this collector's editions are just all
boobs
oh these are definitely photoshopped
yeah poor horse he didn't want to be a
part of this this that is that's a
little bit weird like that looks like a
crime scene thing I'm so desensitized to
this yeah no more words and literally if
there's they have no clothes on there's
no hide in it they're just like in the
water that is what disturbs me is like
just an ass you know I'm gonna say this
is kind of and it was interesting how
quickly they went from like full bush to
completely bare I didn't even really
view these women as actual women
it was more like objects of art I found
my cousin's Playboy once and that was an
awkward experience like I prefer to make
somebody after work for like I don't
like let's just all out there everybody
to see and it isn't you like to be
teased